you know what it is my mom she's one of
those ladies she loves celebrities like
when i did the david letterman show the
first time i well only time i ever did
it john travolta was the other guest
yeah and she was just telling her
friends because you know invited my mom
she would all she was doing it's like
i'm gonna go i'm going to see john
travolta on thursday he's going to be on
letterman and i was like yeah also your
son's doing stand up but she'd never
catch she's like johnny john travolta
john travolta i have a story about him i
met him when i when i did i did stan
this is craig this is 100 true story i
go i go do stand up on david letterman
right and i was so [ __ ] nervous right
of course it's my first time ever on
late night tv i had bought a suit off
the rack from joseph a bank like that
was like shout out shout out joseph
that was 10 times too big and and from
suffolk county long island i bought it
there
shout out
and i go and i go um and and so i'm
standing there john travolta is on the
couch being interviewed by david
letterman like he's done a hundred times
whatever and um i'm [ __ ] my pants
and they go to a commercial break and
i'm going up next and john travolta is
walking by me and he stops and he goes
whoa that's a beautiful suit i was like
thanks i was like i feel like it's two
sizes too big he was like no it's your
shoulder she looks good i was like
thanks i have puffy nipples and
and he goes um he goes uh
um what do you do i was like comedy he
was like it's amazing you've done it
already and i was like no i haven't i'm
actually on next he goes it's over and i
was like no it's not i was like i'm
actually i'm actually going up next and
then he puts his hand on my chest and he
goes your heart's beating so fast i was
like yeah i mean you're massaging my
nipple like you know i feel like i'm
gonna die and he goes it's over you've
done it and i was like
i was like i don't know what you're
saying i don't know what you're saying
i'm trying to tell you that it's not
over i have to do it and he goes listen
to me and it was crazy how he calmed me
down it was so insane he goes listen to
me he goes i'm sure you've had to be
vetted by mr letterman you don't just
show up and do the show you've probably
had to run these few minutes that you've
done a million times if the work is over
now you've lived the fun part it's over
you did it calm down it's over and i and
he goes this is your first time on tv i
said yes he goes i'm going to stay here
and i want to watch you
live this moment i want to watch it all
happen my mother's right outside seeing
all this dying she's like i'm
my john's like i'm going to stand right
here i'm going to watch you live this
moment and i swear to god i was so calm
because with that i'm going on the show
the commercial break is over i'm going
on and he's like i'm gonna be right here
and i was so
calm heartbeat was
where it should be
felt so great i had a what i thought was
a really good set for the first time
ever
in the zone i come off john travolta is
not there i was like where's john and
then the the sound guy was like he left
immediately as soon as you went out here
but i was like you know what that's so
nice of him to just like he did that uh
to just calm me down and then [ __ ]
left just flew in his private jet like
let's get the hell out of here like i'm
not going to stay in watch it's funny
[Music]